noël némouthé bonjour bonjour alors vous
avez été candidat en 2007 aux
législatives en guyane et vous êtes
candidat aujourd'hui en martinique à
fort-de-france pour cette élection de
2022 qu'est ce qui motive votre
candidature
tout d'abord en 2007
tout en étant candidat j'avais demandé
aux gars n'est de ne pas voter pour moi
je n'étais pas venu pour ça j'étais venu
simplement pour faire prendre conscience
de ce qui se passait en guyane et une
fois que j'ai constaté que la majeure
partie de nos hommes politiques guyanais
s'était présentée j'ai trouvé ça
inadmissible et donc j'avais attaqué
tous ces hommes politiques qui faisait
partie de l'exécutif de la guyane en
dehors de madame taubira qui elle ne
faisait pas partie de l'exécutif
alors qu'est ce qui motive aujourd'hui
votre présentation ou législative en
martinique à fort-de-france tout
simplement par coeur en martinique il
n'y a pas de re il n'y a pas de
représentant dit selon c'est à dire
c'est à dire à une époque nous avions
des hommes comme aimé césaire aimé
césaire qui était proche de son papier
tu es avec son peuple et qui étaient là
pour son peuple aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus ces hommes là vous pouvez que les
politiques aujourd'hui sont au sol ne
sont pas proches de poche du peuple mais
les derniers événements nous le
démontrent les derniers événements qui
se sont déroulés avec toutes ces grèves
qui a eu ou nous n'avons pas vu un seul
homme politique
présent aux côtés du peuple aux côtés de
la population en dehors du bureau du
maire du grau mom il y a eu aucun homme
politique je leur avais d'ailleurs
demandé de démissionner lorsque j'avais
envoyé ma vidéo pour appeler justement à
ces femmes et blocages martin alors
justement vous étiez sous ces barrages
notamment à carhaix en novembre dernier
cgt sur le barrage de carhaix en tant
que porte parole de ce bar ajustements
et j'étais là justement pour soutenir
ces personnes qui sont actuellement dans
un combat qui se sentent abandonnés de
la population parce qu'il faut que la
population comprenne également parce que
je vais répondre à votre question mais
faut que la population comprenne que
nous avons des gens actuellement
stationnés à l'entrée du port ce sont
des personnels soignants ce sont
également des dépôts pieds des gens qui
ont été mis à la porte de leur travail
et qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent sans
aide je lance cet appel je lance cet
appel mais momo même au mépris de ce que
j'ai à dire me concernant concernant ma
politique je lance un appel pour tous
les martiniquais pour dual aider ces
personnes emmené leurs amants j'ai
emmené leur à boire emmener leur du
soutien parce que ces gens ont besoin de
vous je sais ce que c'est que d'être
seuls êtres livré à soi-même nous sommes
des martiniquais nous devons être
solidaires avec ces personnes ces gens
qui hier nous soigner dans les hôpitaux
écurité me do you say pompiers qui nous
transportait ces gens de l'adapei qui
s'occupait de nos personnages et nous
devons être là avec eux nous devons les
soutenir allait les aider ils sont à
l'entrée du port soutenez-le et
continuer à les soutenir le combat n'est
pas fini quelle sorte qu'elles sont les
thèmes que vous allez les grands thèmes
que vous allez développer pendant votre
campagne quels sont les thèmes
prioritaires pour vous les thèmes
prioritaires pour moi c'est la pauvreté
en martinique vous avez date des
personnes âgées qui sont actuellement en
martinique qu'il touche à peine 400 500
euros par mois il ya des hommes
politiques qui sont allés à la ctm qui
ose se présenter ici en tant que député
alors qu'il ne devrait pas moi je pense
que la ctm devrait mettre par exemple en
place aimé césaire faisait à l'époque où
son peuple ce que ces gens se disent
héritier d'aimé césaire et bien aimé
césaire avait mis en place des bandes am
j lorsque vous étiez malade y avait pas
encore la cmu ce sont ces bons qui vous
permettait d'aller vous faire soigner et
bien mettant en place des bandas mg de
300 euros et pieds dans ces gens avec ce
bon ils peuvent à l'air carrefour faire
des courses on leur donne pas l'argent
leur donne des bons
pas faire de publicité mais c'est pas là
oui je parle je n'ai pas quelles grandes
surfaces mais ces gens peuvent aller
faire des courses dans ces grandes
surfaces saison peuvent aller pour se
nourrir parce que c'est dur de rester un
mois sans manger c'est là que je dis que
tous ces gens qui sont élus à la ctm le
peuple leur a fait confiance et bien
messieurs je vous dit s'il vous plaît
arrêtez de jouer avec le peuple vous
avez été élu pour faire un travail
faites votre travail je vous ai donné
qu'un exemple mais il ya tellement
d'idées que je pourrais vous donner il
ya aussi parmi vous exemple soutenir les
pme et les agriculteurs bien sûr je suis
moi même agriculteur de passion
mais comment les soutenir mais par quoi
en faisant quoi mais c'est très simple
messieurs je vais vous donner un exemple
concret vous avez aujourd'hui des
agriculteurs qui travaillent
et par rapport à ce qu'il arrive à
générer au niveau de leur boulot au
niveau de l'eau travail eh bien ces gens
malheureusement lorsqu'il arrive devant
les grandes surfaces on leur achète le
produit à des moindre sou là par exemple
on pourrait me soutenir
noël némouthé je vous remercie
merci
[Musique]